mandalorian I've been watching this show
and I love it your character has not
appeared yet not yet not yet your
character is Mothe Gideon I believe we
have a picture of Moff Gideon and this
is not a spoiler there's moth looks like
an intimidating character but I don't
know anything in fact on all the
Mandalorian fans don't know is this is
gonna be a good character is it gonna be
a bad character is there anything you
can tell us that you're right I'll tell
you all about it
Moff Gideon is a remnant Imperial after
the Empire falls apart right and the
Empire has been divvied up to these
remnant Imperials who will then maintain
order is he good is he bad we don't know
right we don't know we do know that
again the world needs someone to put it
back together
moths seems to know everything about
everyone and no one knows how he gets
his information so he's a tricky
interesting human being that we don't
yet know as much about him as we'd like
to yeah and I'm not going to tell you no
you're not not no because I'm pretty
sure that they've told you if you say
anything I mean he's the spoilers for
this you probably have to sign 900
documents there's a sniper following you
you can't say anything about you know
the sniper is right behind me I know it
yeah and he has got me in his crosshairs
I will say this the world in which some
of you have probably seen the first few
episodes of Star Wars I have it is the
Mets why I wore my cowboy boots you know
I'm in a space-age cowboy first
live-action Star Wars series ever and I
am in heaven I have to ask you all the
world is talking about baby Yoda and how
amazingly popular baby Yoda is and
and I'm just gonna put it up cuz it's so
adorable there's baby Yoda in fact
that's the new opening of my show is
that instead of showing pictures of me
we're just gonna show that photo of baby
Yoda and say it's the Conan show never
mentioned baby Yoda which is live off
his his personality I would I'm curious
how your character is going to interact
with baby Yoda
because you seemed I just got so just
saw that picture of baby Yoda and then I
look at your character and I think does
your is your character's heart melted by
baby or do you think me personally I'm
extremely melted by baby Yoda it has
such an incredible obviously in those
eyes intelligence and sweetness and
balance of childlike wonder with very
adult intelligence you can see it in in
in this baby's eyes we're all very
interested and we want the baby what's
the reason why well we'll have to watch
and find out or you could tell us right
now
Gustavo Fring you're getting there
I'm just gonna put this up on the web
because I know people believe this is if
you team up with baby Yoda if your
character and baby Yoda team up both the
most intimidating and least intimidating
forces in the universe working together
working together to save the world